just moments ago a federal judge in
Florida has blocked the bite
administration's plan that would have
released migrants into the United States
without
scheduled court dates we talked about
this last night joining us now Texas
Congressman chip Roy Congressman we were
flabbergasted on air last night when we
first heard that this was happening the
administration argued that if the
releases were blocked the border patrol
would have 45 000 migrants in custody by
the end of the month and that they
couldn't handle it it would be
catastrophic your response to the court
saying nice try but no way tonight
well the Court's doing what it should do
just like a Texas Court was trying to
force this Administration to enforce
micro protection protocols when they
abandoned those after the Trump
administration had successfully taken
policies to make sure they'd secure the
border the fact is the bite
Administration doesn't care and Laura
they don't really care about the rule of
law at all they're ignoring existing law
dumping people into the United States
endangering Texans endangering migrants
at the same time and the fact is as Ted
and Roger just sat down at the southern
Border Texas is under state of Siege we
have a state of emergency in El Paso a
state of emergency in Laredo a state of
emergency in Brownsville I represent San
Antonio they're overflowing migrant
centers overflowing we are getting
absolutely inundated and this
Administration doesn't seem to care and
they're trying to say that they that
they should be able to release people
into the United States without a notice
to appear in court it's absolutely
insane they have the power to stop this
but they refuse to thankfully in the
House of Representatives today we pass
legislation to force the hand of the
administration to do the right thing it
is the strongest border security bill
ever passed through the United States
Congress in this case the House
Representatives we need to get the
Senate to act and the president to move
Republicans have to use the power of The
Purge to Force action through the debt
ceiling or the spending fight September
yeah Congressman um I'm calling you chip
because I feel like I know you so well
but Congressman
um is that bill though Dead on Arrival
in the U.S Senate Biden would certainly
veto it but I think we got some
Republican Senators do we not in the U.S
Senate that would say uh-uh a little too
tough there
well look I'd like to see them do that
in the face of the abject disaster we're
seeing right now on the southern border
but that's not actually the question the
question is whether Republicans will
force through the power of the purse the
question of whether we must secure the
border and actually with all due respect
to Roger for whom I have great respect
we can't wait two years for impeachment
removal through the elected process
now I think the house Judiciary
Committee should take up articles of
impeachment against my orcas we need to
act we need to impeach them we need to
keep putting up pressure we need to use
the debt ceiling and let me just be very
clear don't expect my vote to be
guaranteed right now on any debt ceiling
or any spending Bill unless we're
dealing with the Border we've got to
deal with it it's a crisis for Texas
Republicans need to keep moving forward
but this bill today was historic don't
don't let that slide by In This crisis
this bill was an historic Bill we need
to hold their feet to the fire just like
we're doing with the debt ceiling
Republicans are united in the house and
we're changing the game
well Congressman Roy if we waited two
more years and just impeached my orcas
again my orc is just going to replace
it's like whack-a-mole you get another
mayorkas but if you impeach Biden that
totally is a different message to the
American public I mean I get what they
saying the election's around the corner
but we're going to have 10 million more
people in the country if this spigot is
left open for two years do you not doubt
that we're going to have we could have
upwards of 10 million people across our
border
basically the administration is saying
come on into the country we're going to
release you and look these are
impeachable offenses and some
Republicans try to say that it's not a
high crime of misdemeanor yes it is it's
a blatant violation of their oath to
defend the Constitution to defend the
border of the United States to enforce
the laws my orcas is a liar he lied to
me under oath he lied about the border
patrol agents who he said with patients
and then today he just goes oh never
mind a report said they didn't and he's
never apologized we should impeach him
we should Jam this bill through using
the power of the purse
all right congressman thank you much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else